so how's the girl breast man so I got
the chance to show you bros some more
footage from outlets and I'm really
excited for it I think you bros are
gonna dig it so let's go this place is
pretty cool
hello I can't hear you
follow the blood they said and follow
the blood I shout
hello down there [ __ ] that
confidential not anymore
stop I guess we have to hello hello
anyone in here
batteries my mom is gone any better
uh-huh tell me more tell me my who
plucks your eyebrows huh yeah I didn't
think so
all right what do we do here
uh-huh okay
well it looks like there's nothing for
us here follow the blood they said oh
wait who's pursuing me where the [ __ ] is
pursuing me what oh I'm going here hi
how you doing
well I don't be angry it's gonna be okay
did your mama not how dear enough
hey I'll hug you just kidding you're
ugly
how do I get past him hey hey hey no
reason for us to fight get good job that
get to see him okay
crawling works remember that pills all
right so you gotta you gotta be out of
the minute hey hey hey I didn't know you
weren't a kind of six [ __ ] a duck
don't give me my lock
what happened
did he go in there crazy [ __ ]
okay so he was in here gotcha I wonder
if you can hide underneath the bed
okay well that didn't really go as
planned in it
follow blood trails geez all I got is
this stupid elevated that needs to be
activated there was this there were some
room in where that [ __ ] guy was or
whatever let's just take it easy
let's take it easy one step at a time
girl that guy that guy is cool you're
cool we cool we cool yeah we home
hombres yo max swagger hi
you hit me okay just just get it I'm
just gonna go in here okay just gonna go
in here look at the plant focus on the
plant the plant is your happy place
okay whatever guy just calm down
whatever guy here it has to be something
batteries mnemonics gonna debate a
meaning all right I've had a real oh
okay okay just don't want no trouble now
I'll be on my way sir thank you very
much security this thing's like much
that damn it okay we're back here very
disorienting oh there we go there we go
all right ma'am
follow the blood see my mom made this
game I've been telling you bro so many
times my mom was over not cool not cool
mom I think the hiding I hate it or you
may think I'm in the locker that's
[ __ ] hurt you pizza [ __ ] duck not
cool not cool
[ __ ] ow Yolo okay why can't I just
pick this up and [ __ ] smack people ya
know that's what I always say
oh Jesus the gay couple again Paragons
of patients joke like in the suppression
of our desires but no
I don't know what kind of gay [ __ ] you
guys are into but I'm not interested
okay just sign me out please
I'm okay with you guys doing whatever
don't care it what bet but I don't take
no part in it oh god damn it
Oh God I'm not gonna jump over there are
you crazy
I could die why oh you guys make it
anyway I'm not even gonna go there okay
fine Yolo oh oh well this is
something bad is gonna happen okay
so far so good here we go where did you
follow the blood they said it will be
fine they said okay fine
okay [ __ ] dead people everywhere ah
geez all right you got a key card on you
sir doesn't look like a alright we're
gonna have to find one well it's
probably in here yet I just don't like
it very much
Oh hahahahaha that's me okay that guy
that guy's fabulous swag that's a thing
my boy
man this give us just a [ __ ] joy to
play I'm not gonna lie
no way I could just be like hey you know
what I'm gonna stop no way
all right here we go
No
closing that [ __ ]
exit through the showers what the [ __ ]
does that mean okay
not gonna question it just gonna do it
what the hell just happened oh the gay
couple oh they got me
when it's the showers I don't know what
the showers in darkness that is Yolo
I just
with his belly open
don't do it not worth it my ballet is
ugly I have like an Oprah belly
sorry Oprah they didn't mean to tell you
sorry I'm with the bus let's be honest
here okay
we're alive hey so America Lhasa okay oh
oh oh I'll take it
BAM smack asou oh god jump on jump I do
oh it's you whoa whoa
what you gonna do ha this is five-year
whoa okay Amy oh [ __ ] I got through it
what duck okay that does sound like a
cow don't kill a man for being awesome
going back up don't one huh oh that it's
not working
hey how you doing there sir like to see
ya okay you're dead anyway
well as a oh I'm sorry
what was I supposed to do then Susie
okay press it again I don't [ __ ] know
oh I didn't see that [ __ ] ah hi you too
bad hello ha ha you can fit oh you're
angry now aren't you fatty fat fat
alright okay running behind me [ __ ]
genius jeez open the door
then gently close it oh wait
oh Jesus man I'm having the best day of
my goddamn life I press I hope you
enjoyed if you're excited for this let's
play it's coming up soon
leave a like hit subscribe to come over
today
Oh